buonasera
[Musica]
allora io so che i fantasmi dei natali
passati ma quindi sei qui per mostrarmi
gli errori commessi nel passato
no sono venuto qui per assistere allo
spogliarello dell'indemoniato ripiano
superiore ma ho sbagliato finestra
[Applauso]
beh
beli natali passati no caro babbo natale
quest'anno di ore chiedere una lavatrice
piccole mamme si nasce per poter
finalmente aiutare mia madre nelle
faccende domestiche che questo
l'indeciso succedergli un la pace nel
mondo o di portare in regalo un bambino
dell'africa cazzo mi prende per il culo
questo è il nonno voglio lasciare dei
biscottini il biglietto mi babbo 10 e
mangiati così
ottima già proprio fame si no
[Musica]
pur natiche bordino credo comunque
adesso devo correre perché non vorrei
perdermi lo spettacolo sono e fantasma
dei natali presenti ma qui non c'è uno
spogliarellista adoratrice di sarzana
nosta al piano superiore a quanto dicono
che tali stime tali stanno diventando
sempre più aperta il 10
caro babbo natale basta co ste cazzate
di ogni anno è sono stanche di ricevere
barbie sono collezioni che non gli
faccio proprio più nel senso e dai e
quest'anno arrivato al momento le fiamme
due bozze come du palle da bowling
altrimenti mirko kolcak e mese sbatte no
caro babbo natale
chiederei se potevi proprio moto quando
poi lo fai se no ce la fa niente
facciamo questo quello nuovo di portarmi
la vedrà col gioco ora manzo e chiede le
nevi atrocità di dice volume 3 pub la
borsa la voglia di marca cofanetto
perché se non è di marca non la metto
hai capito non la metto guarda che io la
figura della pezzente quest'anno non c'è
voglio mica fare sto pulsano di merda
battuto reggiano per fame gambe dai e
ciao sono i silenzioso tanta smania di
futuri sì lo strip tease e al piano di
sopra
va bene ci ho provato
ciao anche perché chi vuole sapere come
andranno a finire a tali futuri
molto meglio la sorpresa dai ragazzi
offrendo l'occasione per niente augurare
di tutta la felicità di questo mondo
spero veramente ogni vostro desiderio
ogni cosa che pensate
impossibile possa possa avverarsi
quest'anno buon affare ragazzi